supongamos que tenemos la función fx es
igual a a la x entre x al cuadrado y lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo no es
encontrar la ecuación de la línea
tangente sino la ecuación de la línea
normal cuando x es igual a 1 entonces me
interesa la ecuación de la línea normal
línea
normal no de la tangente aguas y los
invito a pausar este vídeo y tratar de
resolver este problema por ustedes
mismos les voy a dar un hit eso sí lo
voy a hacer les voy a dar un hit
imaginemos que tenemos una curva digamos
esta curva de aquí y entonces yo sé que
la línea tangente en algún punto por
ejemplo en este se ve algo
se ve algo así más o menos más o menos
así se ve la línea tangente entonces
quién es la línea normal pues la línea
normal es una línea que es perpendicular
a la línea tangente y que también pasa
por ese punto de modo que el fin que les
doy es que si la línea tangente tiene
pendiente m entonces la línea normal la
línea perpendicular a la línea tan gente
va a tener pendiente menos 1 / m su
pendiente va a ser el recíproco negativo
de la pendiente de la línea tangente así
que bueno su pondré que ya pasaron el
vídeo y voy a proceder con nuestra
solución y bien lo primero que voy a
hacer es tratar de encontrar la
pendiente de la línea tangente en este
punto para después encontrar la
pendiente de la línea normal y bien como
encontró la pendiente de la línea
tangente en un punto de esta gráfica
pues simplemente toma la derivada voy a
reescribir la función voy a reescribir
fx es igual a ea la x por x a la menos 2
sólo lo escribo así porque la verdad yo
prefiero usar la regla del producto
porque la regla del cociente se me hace
más fácil pero ustedes pueden hacer lo
que ustedes quieran y entonces bien
cuántos y cuánto valdría la derivada de
f cuanto contiene efe prima de x pues
sería la derivada de este primer término
la derivada de ea la x que simplemente
era la x por x al menos 2 más la
derivada de x al menos 2 por ea la x así
que era la x por la derivada de x al
menos 2 la derivada x al menos todos el
exponente baja y me queda menos 2 por x
a la menos 2 -1 que serían menos tres
ésta es la derivada de esta función y
entonces bien cuánto vale la pendiente
cuánto vale f prima en el punto que me
interesa me interesa el punto cuando x
es igual a 1 así que cuánto vale ese
primer 1
junto vale ese prima en uno pues tendría
a la 1 que sencillamente es y por 1 a la
menos 2 que sería uno más
y a la 1 jae por menos dos por uno de
nuevo entonces por menos dos que esto es
lo mismo que a menos dos y que sería
sencillamente menos a esta de aquí esto
sería la
la pendiente pendiente de la tangente
pendiente
la tangente
t
y entonces cuánto vale la pendiente de
la línea normal pues les decía si la
pendiente la tangente m la pendiente de
la línea normal es menos 1 entre m por
lo tanto la pendiente de la línea normal
sería menos 1 / menos que sería
simplemente 1 entre 1 / va a ser la
pendiente de la normal pendiente
de la
normal
muy bien y con eso ya podemos comenzar a
trabajar puede escribir la ecuación de
la línea normal en la forma que es igual
a m x b donde m es la pendiente que es
uno entre y b es la ordenada al origen
ahorita encontramos ver primero que nada
vamos a sustituir lo que sí sabemos yo
sé que la pendiente vale 1 / por lo
tanto es igual a 1 entre e por x + de
ahora yo sé un punto en la ecuación de
la línea normal yo sé que la línea
normal pasa por el punto que tiene
coordenadas x igual a 1
cuando x vale 1 cuánto vale la línea
normal sería por el punto 1 coma de vale
a la 1 entre 1 que sería
cuando x vale 1 f x f de 1 vale
así que x vale 1 vale si sustituye estos
valores a ca obtendría que y es igual a
1 /
1 / e por equis pero x acabo de decir
que vale 1 así que lo voy a ignorar más
de 1 entre más b
de modo que ve y los escribo así sería
sería igual a e menos 1 entre y ahora sí
ya puede escribir la ecuación completa
de la línea normal tendría que la
ecuación de la línea normal es que es
igual a la pendiente que es no entre
vamos a hacerlo con los mismos colores
que es igual a la pendiente que es igual
a 1 /
por x x x + b pero cuánto vale vale
- 1 / y esto de aquí
y esto de aquí
es precisamente la ecuación de la línea
normal